نحن على أحد طرقهم المؤدية إلى
البرلمان ولكن في البداية
تم إغلاق الطريق في الوقت الحالي ،
وقد بدأ أكثر من نصفهم بقليل
مناقشاتهم للتصويت على الثقة
للحكومة الجديدة للزوج
ولكن هناك معارضة شديدة في
الشوارع لما يحدث خلف تلك
الجدران ، فلنتقترب قليلاً مما
نراه هنا ، لقد أطلقوا الغاز المسيل للدموع
مئات من طلقات الغاز المسيل للدموع
على الحشد الذي أطلق النار مرة أخرى بالحجارة
والزجاجات والعصي و
يحاولون الآن هدم هذا الجدار الذي
تم تشييده لمنع الناس من
الاقتراب من البرلمان ،
وقد استمرت هذه الاحتجاجات منذ
17 أكتوبر ، والآن
تستعيد قوتها مرة أخرى وهذا يحدث
على الخلفية.  من الاقتصاد الفاشل ، توقف
الاقتصاد اللبناني
بشكل أساسي
نتيجة لهذه المظاهرات ، لقد وصلنا إلى هناك
وهم يطلقون الغاز المسيل للدموع علينا في
الوقت الحالي.  هذا
وضع يكون فيه حكم هذا
البلد اللبناني مهمة
مستحيلة على الأرجح
، أنا بن ويدمان مراسل سي إن إن من
بيروت